tension toujours vive en rdc la police
est de nouveau intervenu hier pour
disperser des manifestants qui s'étaient
rassemblés autour du parlement à
kinshasa
ils protestaient pour le deuxième jour
consécutif contre trois propositions de
loi concernant le fonctionnement de la
justice
elle porte sur le statut des magistrats
et l'organisation le fonctionnement et
les compétences des juridictions de
l'ordre judiciaire
la coalition au pouvoir depuis janvier
2019 n'est pas sur la même ligne
rappelons que cette coalition est issue
d'un accord entre le président de la
république l'exposant félix tshisekedi
et les forces de son prédécesseur joseph
kabila majoritaire au parlement
pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
alfred shango maître de conférences à la
sorbonne nouvelle bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur un rt
france alors expliquez nous pourquoi
est-ce que ses propositions posent
problème et ce qu'il y a est-ce que la
séparation entre la justice et l'état
est menacée bonjour oui la constitution
de la république démocratique du congo
consacré effectivement le principe de
séparation à de pouvoir et même dans
l'organisation à de la justice il ya un
conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
s'occupe de problème des magistrats et
vous même si le conseil supérieur
justement à dépend du ministère de la
justice mais il n'y a pas d'ingérence en
tant que tel du politique ou du ministre
de la justice dans les questions à
judiciaire et au fond ce qui crispe
l'opinion sait que les trois
propositions qui sont faites par aubin
minaku et son compère sakata c'est de
consacrer l'autorité le pouvoir de
contrôle du ministre de la justice sur
les magistrats du parquet même la
proposition de mettre en place un
conseil un d un procureur
qui serait un espace de discussion des
changes avec le ministre de la justice
va dans ce sens là et puis le pouvoir de
sanction à des magistrats qui revient
normalement au conseil supérieur de la
magistrature dans cette proposition là
on voudrait le déporter vers le ministre
de la justice
c'est cela qui cristallise la colère de
la populaire la révolte qui gronde dans
la dans les rues de kinshasa lubumbashi
à travers la rd congo les plus
fondamentales si aujourd'hui la
coalition au pouvoir est ce qu'elle est
en jeu aujourd'hui cette coalition
alors la coalition est fragilisée depuis
un certain nombre de deux temps c'est à
dire qu' un certain nombre de problèmes
d des faits qui ont surgi qui ont montré
effectivement que l'un des partenaires
justement de cette coalition
le pprd à 2 kabila voulait à tout prix
avoir la mainmise sur la coalition sauf
que tu sais qu'elle dit et kabila ils
s'entendent bien naturellement mais que
tu sais qu'il ya adopté presque la même
attitude donc avait à kabila par le
passé le silence face justement à
l'agitation et sa s'inquiètent beaucoup
dans les rangs du pprd et puis le
dernière fait qui montre effectivement
que les choses sont en train petit à
petit des changes est ce le fait du
silence justement d'étienne tshisekedi
face au procès de son directeur de
cabinet et sa s'inquiètent beaucoup des
caciques du pprd
enfin du fcc qui sont aussi dans l'oeil
du cyclone 1,2 à la justice qui sont
dans le collimateur de la justice
et ils voudraient justement empêcher
qu'on en arrive là dans mon comment est
ce que vous voyez l'évolution de la
balance situation dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines quelle
sortie de crise la seule issue possible
c'est le retrait
de ces trois propositions de loi mais je
crois qu'il ya des manoeuvres en
coulisses qui sont qui se tiennent pour
effectivement amené à aubin minaku à
retirer la proposition de loi parce
qu'on l'a vu même au sein de l'assemblée
dans la commission politique
administrative et justice sakata l'inde
et à ceux qui ont proposé un avec minaku
ces trois projets des propositions de
loi être très embarrassé devant les
députés devant les juristes des gens les
constitutionnalistes il n'a pas su
expliquer le pourquoi
l'opportunité au fond de cette trois
propositions là donc il ya que le
retrait qui va calmer l'opinion mais je
crois que la rupture entre les durs de
partenaires et consommer que certains
même au sein de ce2 de cette coalition
du pprd donc le fcc demande même qu'on
rompe qu'on sorte de la coalition pour
aller vers la cohabitation
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions alfred
shango je rappelle que vous être que
vous êtes maître de conférences à la
sorbonne nouvelle